uh because it's halloween little costume
changes my uh drive jacket i feel pretty
good about that
big uh big fan of daddy gosling you're
uh welcome anytime if you want to do the
show by the way uh so i don't know we've
only done a couple shows but already i
can tell you with honesty that the pete
home show audiences are some of the best
audiences in the world and i want to
thank you so much for coming out and
thank you guys for dressing up for
halloween i think that's wonderful so
how about a round of applause for that
almost
everybody
i i thought only a few people would do
it but it turns out almost everybody in
the audience dressed up for halloween
which i think is wonderful let's give
them a little camera time i think that'd
be nice first off we have look at this
it's a strawberry shortcake that's
lovely
yeah
uh and here's a good one
uh here we have the real meow's wives of
catlanta
meows loves
meows wads
of cat
lanta
meows wives
i actually wanted to go with menopause
my writers told me not to go with
menopause but i uh just went right for
it you're lovely thanks for being here
this is a clark kent if he never figured
out he was superman that's a good one
yeah
uh here this is uh both of the guys from
mythbusters
both of them in one
we rolled them into one
and then we got me and we already know
what i am i'm uh you know i'm daddy gus
huge renee zellweger thank you so much
for that boost to my ego i'm wearing a
drive jacket guys it's a drop
thank you okay wow that's great happy
halloween everybody
you